I'm gonna be honest just for a second
I'm feeling a little frustrated I
actually got a parking ticket this
morning yeah thanks I guess my rear
bumper get this was six inches six
inches in a red zone and they gave me
this ticket it's just sort of bums me
out a little bit oh well maybe I can
help you with it can you bring it over
here can I see it sure you think you can
help yeah yeah yeah
give it a look tell me what you think
take care of Eddie you can't you can't
just rip up a parking ticket it's
against the law not if you commit the
crime in international waters check it
out okay wait a minute
all right stop clapping listen I know my
maritime law don't you have to be like
24 miles from shore to be considered
international waters you have to be 24
miles out not anymore thanks to our
newest sponsor ah the open sea hello
I'm lieutenant Bret ship's a real naval
officer did you know crimes committed
more than 24 miles off the coast of any
country are immune from that country's
laws this safety zone is designated
international waters crimes that would
be considered unthinkable on dry land
can be committed without consequences on
the high seas
and now you can have that same legal
protection without ever leaving the
shore thanks to crimes ahoy bottled
international water
crimes ahoy is bottled at the heart of
the Indian Ocean hundreds of miles from
the nearest sovereign nation and
enjoying it is easy simply fill any
vessel with at least 8 inches of crime
savoy then stand in it and do whatever
you like you can commit illegal acts
with total impunity and how does law
enforcement know you're standing an
authentic bottled international water
and not just some cheap knockoff because
every bottle of crimes ahoy comes with
two ironclad guarantees one a
certificate of authenticity 2 a free
testing kit checks out just present
these items to any law enforcement
officer and rest easy your crime spree
will go unpunished
and don't just take it from me here are
some of our success stories on our wall
of heroes Oh Jay Simpson Casey Anthony
and Barbara Walters
so get crimes ahoy bottled international
water
it's refreshingly exonerating that is so
salty yes
yes that's right that's right yes I'd
like to buy one Blood Diamond please Oh
it's against the law you say how about
now
thanks crimes ahoy
[Applause]
you